who are men more willing to help men or
women
probably women because they've seen
their eyes Okay okay so even if a man is
in a superior position he's more willing
to help you right so so that argument
doesn't make sense if if your boy is
getting hit your boy will jump in and be
like stop paying my boy simple they just
won't have to hit the girl and a lot of
the time the reason why they can wait if
your voice is getting a headache so if
your boy is getting hit and they'll say
stop no no guys get into fights over
this stuff can I just slice that poo
how many times has anybody seen a girl
hit a man and jumps in and said oh don't
hit him never oh I never see that I
never see him thank you and if you had
to and have you never seen it well there
you go may I just say something though
there's a few things I'm so sorry my
love I missed your name again
I like you but there's some things that
you're saying that make me feel very
uncomfortable because first of all it's
like okay you say that I'm sorry to take
your example you got abused you did not
report it that's one thing that
annoys me
people go to social judge social like
Society like social media to be their
judge and I always say to them first
thing go to the police that's the first
thing you're meant to do you're not
meant to go to social media and address
it the reason why the good social media
address is because Society like you said
Auntie Jenny is more acceptable or is
more open to receive
um a complaint from a woman than a
complaint from a man and also abuse are
we talking about only physical abuse
because abuse starts also emotionally
mentally and women are very very good at
that yeah I'm a woman I can say it I
will say it we women are very good at
that so before I'm not justifying any
physical abuses not justifiable let's
say that as a disclaimer but abuse
starts before even hands get laid on and
who starts that most times women
[Music]
um
what also doesn't make sense to me is if
you didn't go to the police but you're
assassinating his character on a public
platform so it doesn't really make sense
because people know who you dated so
anyone that knows you that sees this
podcast anyone that knows me knew I went
through it but I'm saying like why are
you able to assassinate his character
but you're not able to go to the police
because now I'm over it I can talk about
it is easy when I was going through and
this is the thing about abuse that
people don't understand it goes beyond
physical it's almost like you're under
this crazy trance it's true because a
woman like me for any anyone that knows
me you guys at home that actually do
know me if you saw the ones that did see
me like just a year ago you'll never
believed I'm the same person because I
know actually the thing is we talk about
abuse and unless you've gone through it
you really don't understand what it does
mean and why it's so deep and why
actually some people as that girl said
are really fearful because it's really
deep I stayed stuck for five years I
couldn't leave I felt you say it wasn't
that deep
well you know she said that it was
perceived by by her culture as not that
yeah it wasn't that bad not that it was
no it was perceived yeah yeah it was
perceived yeah of course because I go I
tried
I trust family even with my family I
didn't even stopped speaking to my
family because I couldn't leave him I
was still going through the situation my
family was just so scared all the time
right I stayed away when I approached
the family so why are you complaining
like stop you why why is it you made him
angry you need to like structure this
right so so you said initially you said
it wasn't that bad but now you're saying
it wasn't that bad relative to the
culture is that what you're saying now
yeah he's relative to the culture okay
cool what is what what happened he like
punched you in the face too many things
do many things like so many many things
that I don't even need to go into the
cause of my body yeah everything makes
sense like it like punched me in the
face I I would go to the police but have
you heard of Stockholm syndrome oh my
God all these times listen Guys these
feminists have the craziest vocabulary
listen I'm telling you right now
emotional Stockholm syndrome
I know it's Stockholm when women fall in
love with their Captor
chapter he was your boyfriend and then
he became abusive because he abused it
from this I'll give you a little
breakdown into how it goes so you fall
in love with somebody they love bomb you
you're amazing you think it's the best
time in the world you find your prince
charming One day things start to attract
the compliments start turning into this
little criticism and then it grows and
grows and grows by the time you get hit
you're already desperately madly in love
with this person you think that they're
you're forever and after you commit you
dedicate by the time things get really
wrong you've already given everything
and you're thinking how am I going to
leave this situation where do I go what
happens oh my God then on top of that
I'm a woman I've been with you all this
time if I leave I'm not that much good
there's so many things that actually
Society does do actually even like allow
these situations to go on we can
complain and say that no you are alive
when you don't report it that's right
because you can't let that man leave
like you can't leave that man and tell
him I'm not gonna represent him and not
fear for the next woman that's my only
issue here do you understand and I can
appreciate the difficulty but then this
is why you think that women are on the
losing inside because if he's still on
at large with no repercussions and only
just Society telling pointing the thing
and be like he's bad that's not enough
can I just say something right as far as
I'm concerned the man ain't done [ __ ] to
you the money does [ __ ] to you because
you're on a I can turn around and say
yes my son's dad was abusive I put it
down on the police records you know what
because he knows it's out there and he
knows that the police knows about it and
it's been out there we've been to court
right but as far as I'm concerned
yours never happened if I was that man
and you're here it's defamation of
character because there is nothing there
on paper to say that the man abused you
and that's what Paul was saying you're
here telling thousands of people that
this man abused you what evidence have
you got that he that he abused you okay
as far as I'm concerned you could fall
down the stairs and brush your knee and
give them scars because there's nothing
legal on paper to say that he was abused
hang in a minute let me finish he can
turn around today and he can say do you
know what defamation a character because
there's nothing there on paper and she's
there telling the error the whole world
that I'm abusive if I'm abusive where is
the record and that's the problem too
many people go out there and then who
have been abused whether it's men or
women and they make all these
accusations in public without any proof
and as far as I'm concerned if I was a
man and I was beating on a woman and the
woman ain't got the guts enough to go to
the police and report it but she's got
guts enough to go and sit down on social
media and tell the whole world I'm gonna
go and take it out
I'm gonna go and take it up because as
far as I'm going to come that's
defamation a character let him come I've
got plenty of evidence
you ain't got no evidence
I called into the law because if you had
evidence the police would have had the
evidence
right now but you've never done it I
didn't do it you never I don't care why
you ain't done it because as far as I'm
concerned if you ain't done it in my
view it ain't it hasn't happened it has
not happened
on paper I definitely won't be living in
the UK for too long what do you mean
I'll take those inside how do you know
where I live how do you know where I
live we have the same with no I said
that I was raised I was born here and I
raised and I also told you that I go to
Barbados three times a year so where I
come from has got nothing to do and if
you didn't insult me insult me properly
as far as I'm concerned you're sitting
down there and you're talking about
respecting your elders and then you're
gonna come and tell me some [ __ ]
like that well let me tell you right it
don't matter if I was abusing Barbados I
would have been reporting it in Barbados
more likely that they wouldn't even help
I was done what are you talking about
don't knock it till you've tried it you
can't do you can't talk about it I know
I've tried it no you can't talk about
what you don't know you ain't tried it
because you already said you did not
report it and you can't talk about the
laws in Barbados because the laws in
Barbados are up to cue with the laws in
the west let me tell you that the laws
in the west don't work they got them
they don't work if you don't damn well
use them if you don't use the noise
how can it work for me how come it work
for me no how can we work for me I
reported that how can it worked for me
all right now I'm gonna ask myself that
because I am not relaxed bringing down
somebody on social media just for
publicity stuff don't need publicity
that's why they're talking about all the
stats because the stats will be all out
of sync because of people like that you
can't turn around and therefore make
somebody's character for no reason as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible